THURSDAY MAY TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER PLEASE BE ADVISED ON
AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE
HAS ALSO BEEN TELEVISED-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDED
A CERTAIN MUST WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES AND COMPLY WITH
GUIDANCE ON PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
ATTENDEES MUST ALSO REFRAIN
FROM CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS
HEARING. VIOLATION OF THESE
RULES MAY SUBJECT INDIVIDUALS
REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HERE
CUNNINGHAM SENATE HERE LARA.
GIPSON YEAH WE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS YOUR RAMOS RUBIO. THE
APPROVAL WEBER. YOUR CAR WE
HAVE A- WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA MOVE MOVE
OUR MOST AMOUNT SECOND MISTER
GIPSON. OF KYZER RESEARCHER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOVED AND
SECONDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM SENATE HI HI FLORA
FLORA HIGH GIPSON. GIPSON
HIGHLY MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MATHIS MATHIS FYROM US
RUBIO RUBIO HIVE YOU PULA WEBER.
WEBER HI. MOTION PASSED MOTION
PASSES AND OF THIS RULES
COMMITTEE ALL RELEASE YOU ALL
SIT HERE FOR A MOMENT THIS IS A
COLLEAGUES ARRIVED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WITH A- THE PREFIX
LONG. IT'S BEEN REALLY GOOD ARE
YOU DOING WELL. THANK.YEAH
YEAH REPUBLICAN. THEY. HI WE
HAVE- CAN AGENDA RAMOS RUN I
FEEL WHAT VEHICLE WELL HI.
LEAVE IT OUT EXCUSE ME-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEON CONSENT HI
LEE HI. OVER ONE. OKAY. WITH
THE L. ON THE OTHER LINE. RIGHT
SOME OF WILL CHOOSE TO BE WITH
WITHOUT HAPPENED. THAT'S RIGHT.